bundespräsident steinmeier wollte nach
kiew reisen aber dann holte ihn
bekanntlich seine vergangenheit als
putin verstehen der ukrainische
präsident see lenski wollte ihn deshalb
so gar nicht anfangen das wiederum
führte dazu dass sein parteifreund und
bundeskanzler olaf scholz auch nicht
nach kiew reisen wollte noch gestern
sagte er die ausladung steinmeiers
stünde dem weg heute nur einen tag
später sieht die sache plötzlich ganz
anders aus und unser reporter paul
ronzheimer kann uns erklären warum paul
ja endlich thomas hat es ein klärendes
gespräch geben von florian selensky mit
frank walter steinmeier darüber wie man
hier weiter zusammenarbeiten kann und
das hat dazu geführt dass es jetzt eine
möglichkeit wieder gibt nicht beide
wurden eingeladen von
präsident steve der bundeskanzler wurde
eingeladen und der bundespräsident ein
kleiner rückblick wie erinnern uns ist
war um den 14 april als bild damals
exklusiv enthüllt hat wie er enthüllt
haben das von peter stein nicht
willkommen war er war gerade auf einer
reise in polen und da hat er in dieser
ausladung getroffen und danach gab es
ein hin und her olaf scholz hat das
heftig kritisiert und hat gesagt
deswegen kann er nicht fahren deswegen
will er nicht fahren es gab natürlich
kritik an bundeskanzler jetzt scheint
das gelöst es ging ursprünglich ja um
die russland freundliche politik von
frank walter steinmeier aber jetzt
scheint es gelöst und beide können
kommen
die frage ist wann
das ist noch unklar jetzt wird erstmal
bärbel bas in die ukraine kommen am 8 9
mai wird sie erwartet das ist ein
wichtiges ein historisches datum auch
für die ukraine
und am 9 bei der kapitulation
nazideutschlands bewusst in russland als
feiertag begangen wird da erwartet man
möglicherweise eine neue mobilisierung
der russischen armee das deutete die
britische regierung an man hat dort
offenbar erkennen ganz klar ist es nicht
aber fakt ist was dort passiert was dort
gesagt wird das wird am ende dafür
sorgen in welche richtung dieser krieg
gehen wird wie kann es sein das auch
friedrich merz der ja zu wochenbeginn in
kiew mit selen ski zusammentraf da
vielleicht weichen gestellt hat dass es
zu dieser versöhnung jetzt gekommen ist
um es mal so zu nennen
das ist das was friedrich merz sagt er
sagt er habe das angesprochen um
gespräch mit brasiliens gibt ehrlich
gesagt ich hab's ja ein bisschen meine
zweifel dass der ukrainische präsident
friedrich merz dazu braucht um dann zum
hörer zu greifen es gibt informationen
wonach sozusagen das jüngste interview
von olaf scholz der auslöser war also wo
er noch einmal wiederholt hat dass er
nicht bereit ist zu kommen dass er
wütend ist auf die ukraine das er
beleidigt ist und danach hat man
offenbar im präsidenten im umfeld des
ukrainischen präsidenten sich dazu
entschlossen das jetzt aus dem weg zu
räumen zumal ja auch ist eine änderung
der deutschen politik richtung schwerer
waffen bereits gab also der erste
schritt aus sicht der ukraine gegangen
ist und man dann sozusagen das auch aus
dem weg räumt wollte paul friedrich merz
drängt auch darauf heute die deutsche
botschaft in kiew wieder zu öffnen so
schnell wie möglich sowie andere länder
das schon getan haben wieder mache
deutschland den eindruck zögerlich zu
sein du kannst es einschätzen du bist du
vor ort in der ukraine
du warst über zwei monate auch in kiew
ist es inzwischen dort sicher genug um
das deutsche personal wieder nach kiew
zu bringen
ja ich hatte kiew für sicher genug ich
meine man darf ja nicht vergessen die
deutsche botschaft hat es zum beispiel
vor der übernahme der taliban auch in
kabul gegeben auch da gab es attacken
angriffe man muss sicherlich
sicherheitsvorkehrungen beachten aber es
haben ja schon mehrere botschaften
bereits gesagt dass sie zurückkommen
jetzt heute die kanadische botschaft ich
gehe davon aus dass die deutsche
regierung dass das deutsche
außenministerium das im gleichschritt
mit den europäischen partnern machen
will denn man wird sicherlich eine
eu-lösung richtung dort finde ich gehe
aber davon aus dass das in den nächsten
wochen passieren wird also die lage in
kiew momentan etwas sicherer in
anführungsstrichen wie sieht es bei dir
unten an der front aus an der front zum
dombach
thomas hier entwickelt sich der krieg
insbesondere in den dörfern und da sieht
man wie die russen langsam aber stetig
voran kommen und dennoch können die
ukraine sich noch verteidigen ich sage
nur noch weil es offenbar ein problem
mit der munition gibt ein problem damit
gibt das die russen was schwere waffen
angeht ihnen gerade hier sehr überlegen
sind etwas positives wir aus sicht der
ukraine wir sind heute aus dem highway
richtung constantin oft gefahren und
plötzlich mit zwei fighter jet die sehr
tief geflogen sind und wir dachten
zunächst das wäre eine russische
kampfjets aber tatsächlich waren es
ukrainische jets die wir dort gesehen
haben und das ist doch einigermaßen
erstaunlich und beeindruckend dass die
ukraine selbst hier im donbass noch eine
lufthoheit haben das hätte man ihn zu
beginn des krieges gar nicht zugetraut
informationen von unserem reporter paul
ronzheimer in der ukraine vielen dank